what stage
would sarah have realised something was
wrong
[Music]
it's really sad to think
that she's that quite scary situation
that she's in at that point
on the evening of march the 3rd 2021
pc wayne cousins was waiting
it's clear
isn't it that the only reason he was
here was to abduct
a woman
[Music]
so we're here to talk to you
about
the picture
no sarah i don't know on the 30th of
september 2021
former police officer wayne cousins was
sentenced to a whole life order for
abducting raping and murdering 33 year
old marketing executive sarah everard
he spent at least a month preparing for
his crimes
on the 3rd of march at 9 00 pm miss
everard leaves her friend's house on
leithwaite road clapham
at 9 13 pm she calls her boyfriend for
around 14 minutes at 9 15 miss everard
was captured alone on cctv at the
junction of bowwood road and the a205
the south circular
the next sighting is 9 28 p.m when she
is on cavendish road and she's still
alone
even as a man you think it's the most
safest route to come home it's well lit
with street lighting and plenty of
properties around so yes i think that's
the route that she would have taken in
every time she went to see her friend
seven minutes later a bus camera
captures miss everard and wayne cousins
on poinders road standing beside a white
vauxhall astra parked on the pavement
with hazard lights on
earlier that day cousins had hired this
car from dover in kent
at 9 38 another camera captures the same
vehicle with the two front doors open
he could have used covid as a as a
reason to get her into the back of the
car and said you're breaching coving
rules and
arrested her you know sarah wouldn't
necessarily have known every single law
and he could have made one up to get in
the back of the car
the car is next spotted at 1am in
tillman stone in kent at 8 30 am cousins
returns the hire car to dover and is
spotted at a local costa coffee
sarah everard's body is found six days
later at hodes wood near ashford kent
police don't know exactly where and when
cousins murdered sarah but they do know
that for a while he stored her body here
hidden amongst this rubbish
under a freezer
days after this cousins were spotted in
a b and q store in dover
buying two builders bags which he's
believed to have used to transfer
sarah's body
then cousins came back
and using some kind of trolley
brought sarah's body 250 yards or so
into the woods
and left her in this shallow water
on the morning of the 7th of march
cousins took his family to the same
woods where he'd dumped sarah's body in
an apparent bid to create an alibi
well i am in financial
and i've been lent on by
it then came through that
they're gonna
harm my
family take them away and they'll use
them instead
um but at that point i had no option
wayne cousins had been vetted by police
and had no criminal record
but he had been accused of indecent
exposure at a mcdonald's restaurant
the police watchdog is currently
reviewing how those allegations were
handled when you tell your children
or you tell as a friend or whatever you
know if you're in trouble
try and find a police officer what he
did that day
has set that back
uh to such a distance behind us that
we've you know you try and recover and
you try and
say we're not like that
[Music]
[Applause]
there are no words that can fully
express the fury and overwhelming
sadness
that we all feel about what happened to
sarah
i am so
sorry
sarah's death sparked nationwide
protests and vigils
for his crimes wayne cousins has been
told he'll never be released from prison
you